and now a message from your local nerd
rider oh sorry didn't see you there hi
I'm the nerd rider and this week I'm on
my fifty second blog that's a year's
worth of vlogs so it's sort of a special
occasion so what I'm gonna do is a
question and answer vlog now people have
asked me a lot of stuff in the comments
before and I've never really answered
anything outright so here's your chance
ask me anything you want in the comments
of this video and next week I'll do a
vlog where I answer as many as I can
also if you haven't watched my blog from
last week vlog 51 New York City please
do and vote for me and my destination
calms the biggest baddest bucket list if
you think it would be cool to see me
show you and teach you the world I think
it would be pretty cool well actually
I'd love to stay and talk more but I
have a prior engagement so ask your
questions I'll see you next time